et le 22 mai prochain que se déroulera
le concours eurovision de la chanson un
événement international qui comme chaque
année sera diffusé sur france 2 condamné
le concours aura lieu avec ou sans
public mais avant de savoir si nous
aurons la chance de gagner au mans ce
concours la première étape est d'abord
de désigner notre représentant c'est la
raison pour laquelle l'émission rebillon
france c'est vous qui décidez a été créé
sans moi
[Musique]
dix-sept candidats vont donc s'affronter
contenter de convaincre le public ils
sont les meilleurs pour faire briller
les couleurs de la france dans le
concours européen parmi eux on retrouve
dix artistes solos trois duos et un trio
c'est le public n'est pas seul juge en
effet des célébrités formeront également
un jury qui aidera le choix du candidat
désigné
un jury sera présidé par amir candidats
l'eurovision en 2016 avec sa chanson
j'ai cherché
autour de lui on retrouvera notamment
marie myriam et natasha st-pier deux
artistes qui ont également participé au
concours mais aussi des célébrités plus
étonnantes comme elodie gossuin jean
paul gaultier ou encore michèle bernier
alors le jury de l'eurovision 2021 est
il à la hauteur de l'événement
ouais le jury de l'eurovision est il à
la hauteur de l'événement visiblement
oui comme ça
vu comme ça ça fait pas très beau
écoutez ça donne envie et puis je suis
confiant surtout que cette émission qui
marche un peu dans les pattes de
destination eurovision de vous en
souvenez car qui avait notamment régler
bilel pardon monsieur et tout donc enfin
de nouveau les gens pourront choisir un
jury très sympathique très feelgood très
éclectique conte avec on n'a pas
l'habitude de voir dans ce genre
d'exercice puisqu'ils viennent pas d'eux
delà de la scène musicale pour tous mais
ça donne envie
vous savez qui a produit la première
émission de sélection de l'eurovision
c'était vous présentez pas mais j'allais
au caire mettez-vous jamais barça qui en
a eu qu'une d'ailleurs
alors j'ai un comprendre c'était un fou
voilà on a en effet des quotidiennes et
sert à ses premiers trophées
voilà oui j'ai l'argile vous vous aimez
moi j'aime bien mire j'adore natasha
st-pier que l'injure effectivement il ya
des profils différents
je suis souvent sévères à propos de
l'eurovision je pense que la france
présente des candidats qui sont pas
terribles mais là je crois ce jury je
crois que le public va faire le bon
choix et ça cette année pour une fois je
suis optimiste de dieudonné match parce
que stéphane bern et laurence boccolini
moi là bas j'avais j'étais pas trop pour
mais en fait là je trouve que ça va très
bien marché ils n'ont pas trop d'ego
l'un avec l'autre donc ils vont pas trop
essayé de ce marché l'un sur l'autre
donc je pense ça a plutôt bien
fonctionné cette nouvelle édition là
c'est un peu le mariage de la carpe et
du lapin mais on a envie de voir
ligny par rayon de la première chose
qu'elle a dit quand elle est arrivée à
france télévisions sais je rêve de
présenter leur vision des affaires
motivé en plus tous les deux se
connaissent depuis plus de vingt ans
parce qu'ils étaient à la radio ensemble
ils ont une grande complicité
donc je vraiment j'y crois à ce bio et
ils sont contents de le faire ce qui est
quand même un atout alors parmi les
candidats il ya on parle beaucoup d'un
adagio cpo nice à ses intérêts qui a sur
la tête à marc un masque de beauté c'est
comme ça on vous dit pourquoi mag le
poney dans bassinger mais dans leur
vision et pourtant ça fonctionne pas mal
le titre s'appelle amour fou je crois on
a un petit extrait regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous chantez gérer à la fois je trouve
ça pas mal c'est un filtre qui est
disponible en plus sur tous les
téléphones tout ça fait très eurovision
donc mon avis ça va ça va ça va on a des
chances avec l'eurovision c'est quoi ces
se démarquer c'est avoir un look y avoir
quelque chose je suis désolé et le
chanteur a quand même accompagné
offenbach 1 je connais pas la culture de
nuit pas non c'est très chevaleresque
moi j'aime bien cette sélection beaucoup
cette vanne
[Rires]
il n'est pas célibataire
voilà on leur souhaite bonne chance
oui oui je voulais préciser je pense que
c'est pas à l'abri de bien fonctionner
on avait fait des sondages sur
télé-loisirs par les animateurs que les
gens avaient le plus envie de voir
laurence boccolini était 3e et stéphane
bern était 2e ou 3e quelque chose quand
même donc les gens ont envie de voir
encore plus et je pense que le duo il va
être mais à mourir de rire
il peut très bien fonctionner fort de
france télé donc c'est ça qui est bien